pour en parler sur ce plateau alexis
poulain éditorialiste à thé france
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous marcel
bénézet président de la branche cafés
bars brasseries du groupement national
des indépendants bonsoir marcel b les et
merci d'être avec nous et on duplex
pierre tattevin
épidémiologistes chef du service des
maladies infectieuses au chu de rennes
bonsoir pierre tattevin merci aussi de
nous accompagner ce soir gabriela taille
qui a donc annoncé 1 3 pistes
principales à l'étude pour endiguer
cette cinquième vague renforcement des
mesures barrières le port du masque en
intérieur et en extérieur on y retourne
le renforcement du passani terre pour
mettre davantage de contraintes sur les
non vaccinés et évidemment
l'accélération de la campagne vaccinale
il faut agir de manière forte perte
advint
oui je pense qu'en tout cas les deux
premiers pans de ce qu'ils ont proposé
la d essayer de faire un peu d'effort
sur les mesures barrières et puis
d'améliorer la couverture vaccinale avec
cette dose de rappel qui permet vraiment
de récupérer beaucoup d'efficacité du
vaccin était prioritaire pour le pass
annie terre c'est toujours un peu
dommage d'être obligé de passer par des
des contraintes légales pour convaincre
les gens qu'il faut qu'ils soient
vaccinés mais en tout cas les deux
premiers pensons vraiment indispensable
pour essayer d'atténuer un peu ce qui
nous attend alors il faut faire peser la
contrainte sur les français qui ont fait
le choix de ne pas se faire vacciner 1
c'est gabriel a le talent qu'il dit
aujourd'hui
l'exécutif qui clairement veut inciter
voire presque contraindre les personnes
non encore vaccinés à le faire alexis
blanc ça elle mérite au moins de la
clarté oui c'est ce qu'on voit dans tous
les régimes on a vu justin dardenne
aussi en nouvelle zélande et non
vaccinés ils ont tu dois et c'est comme
ça elle rit y est d'ailleurs encore
d'ailleurs à un gouvernement de gauche
c'est assez étonnant l'impression que ce
jeu là se joue à opposer les uns contre
les autres devant finalement l'inanité
des mesures la capacité de ce
gouvernement a géré cette crise il n'est
pas le seul dans cette une crise
mondiale mais ce surplace depuis deux
ans il fait du mal il fait du mal au
pacte républicain le conseil
constitutionnel a validé ces mesures
liberticides du pass à lithaire on
continue on va toujours plus loin avec
maintenant le bouc émissaire du non
vaccinés celui là qui seraient à
l'origine de l'épidémie sachant que les
vaccinés bien peuvent aussi transmettre
le virus est la question qui se pose
alors les enfants les enfants dès 5 ans
qui sont aussi là une poche épidémique
terrible hein on entend maintenant la
vaccination des enfants qui commencent à
arriver puisque aux etats-unis elle a
commencé les laboratoires comme pfizer
ont dit qu'il n'y avait aucun risque on
pouvait y aller donc c'est un débat qui
va falloir avoir sans doute un débat
difficile je pense en france mais qui va
se poser puisque si on commence à
montrer du doigt le non vaccinés alors
les premiers ils sont 10 millions ce
sont les enfants de 5 à 11 ans on va en
parler mais on va d'abord regarder
alexis regarder ses réponses à face aux
pays européens qui font eux aussi
évidemment face à cette cinquième vague
je dirais que c'est encore pire regardez
l'autriche confinement total pays-bas
fermeture bars et restaurants ça vous
concernant marcel bénézet un bar et
restaurant à 20h01 slovaquie confinement
des non vaccinés tout simplement et
allemagne accès interdit à certains
lieux publics pour les non vaccinés
avant d'interroger leurs représentants
des restaurateurs pierre tattevin on
peut se dire que c'est encore pire dans
les autres pays ça veut dire quoi qu'on
a vraiment pas le choix pour endiguer
cette cinquième vague ces restrictions
qui peuvent effectivement choqué sur le
plan des libertés individuelles
on peut aussi voir une petite note
positive c'est quand même la france on
est parti de très bas on était des
champions du monde de l'hésitation
vaccinale ya encore un an dans une
campagne de vaccination qui est mal
parti et au cours de l'année 2000 21 on
arrive à des taux de couverture
vaccinale qui sont plutôt tout à fait
honorable et qui explique probablement
pourquoi on n'est pas des incidences à
1400 comme l'autriche donc on n'est pas
si mal que ça alors qu'on partait parmi
les derniers de en termes de couverture
vaccinale
marcel bénézet quand vous voyez
effectivement c'est ces mesures dans les
pays européens
vous vous dites quoi bon pour l'instant
on souffle c'est ce qui nous va nous
tomber dessus et vous êtes très inquiet
on est très inquiet la profession est
très clair j'étais justement dans mon
taxi en venant ici vous rejoindre j'ai
eu deux appels de restaurateurs mais
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui va se passer
demain qu'est ce qu'on va nous dire
alors moi je redis surtout de respecter
de contrôler le pass anitea c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya eu des sites des
relâchements il faut reconnaître c'est
même moi même allé dans des restaurants
où j'ai pas été contrôlés
ready important je dis attention parce
que si on peut pas se permettre de
refermer notre établissement si demain
on referme nos établissements
économiques aux mains déjà l'europe les
aides c'est terminé la france peut plus
se permettre aujourd'hui on peut plus se
permettre de l'argent facile comme ça
c'est impossible donc aujourd'hui il
faut rester ouvert par tous les moyens
l'anglo pas sanitaire c'est un outil les
gestes barrière sénateur mais il faut
contrôler il faut contrôler sans cesse
nos clients des tirs entre faire
demander le contrôle du pass à lithaire
qui deviendra le passé l'accident et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut coller les
français aillent se faire vacciner la
troisième dose pour ceux qui peuvent la
faire et se fasse faire signer
aujourd'hui nous avons fait ça donc je
sais que c'est compliqué mais nous
allons encore vivre des heures
difficiles des journées difficiles des
mois difficiles noël approche et une
paella montagne vous rendez compte tous
les gens qui vont partir aujourd'hui la
montagne réservation les gens comptait
partir à l'étranger ou partir en
vacances qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
aujourd'hui il ya une inquiétude et je
vous assure et psychologiquement
aujourd'hui les français et les
restaurateurs mais des français en
général et même l'autre et même sur tous
nos salariés sont très atteints
psychologiquement parce que on est dans
une certitude totale j'espère qu'on ne
fermera pas je souhaite me rendre ne
ferment pas d'ailleurs alexis poulain
c'est vraiment ce que l'argument brandi
socialement le gouvernement l'argument
économique et quand on entend marcel
bénézet évidemment on peut quand même
comprendre à partir du moment où il n'y
a pas d'autre solution et c'est ça c'est
ça le problème c'est que on est dans une
logique économique de absolument ne par
confiner parce que de toute façon
c'était une erreur déjà tragique la
premier confinement on s'en est pas
remis en réalité on a fait une dette
phénoménale on a essayé de soutenir des
secteurs qui sont auto effondré bref
c'est scandaleux mais on a la même
logique que le tinal deyris nos
alternatives des néolibéraux des
thatcher qui disent on ne peut pas faire
autrement on a ignoré certains
traitements on a limité finalement la
recherche on arrive maintenant avec des
nouveaux médicaments pour traiter
précocement pfizer merck et d'autres
labos qui arrive on a acheté très cher
170 millions le ban l'image du
laboratoire lilly dix médicaments
dangereux inutiles 170 millions d'euros
qui ont été cramé en fumée moi je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un vrai problème
fondamental c'est la gestion de cette
crise en france particulièrement sous le
sceau du secret défense il faut demander
maintenant que cette gestion crise soit
collé collégiale qu'elle ne soit pas
faite sous le sceau du secret défense
les français ont le droit de savoir ce
qui s'est passé pourquoi des vision un
patchwork de décision finalement sans
queue ni tête aujourd'hui le ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui on va laisser
les classes ouvertes on va continuer de
faire comme s'il n'y avait pas de covin
pour une certaine taille de la
population et pour les autres c'est la
troisième dose ou plus de passes ça
suffit je croyais qu'on a envoyé trois
de voix c'est encore pire dans les
autres pays on confine en autriche en ce
moment
des choix mais est ce qu'on a le choix
aujourd'hui on a le choix puisque arrive
des traitements qui on espère vont
fonctionner le vaccin on a appris tous
les six mois qu'il marchait de moins en
moins bien tous les six mois il sera
elle parle de quatrième dose en dix ans
on sera obligé de faire une quatrième
dos pour certaines catégories de la
population donc le recul on l'a en
avançant on n'a pas vraiment de recul
donc je croire que le problème qu'on a
avec nos gouvernants dans le monde
entier sait qu'il ya pas de plan b on a
mis des milliards sur la table pour un
vaccin pensant qu'il serait à 95% utile
et qu'on mettrait le coup vite derrière
nous ce n'est pas le cas donc on se
retrouve là sans plan b et il faut
bricoler avec les médicaments qui
arrivent avec les confinements les
mesures de confinement sur une certaine
catégorie de la population mais vous
avez des pays même vacciné ou savard
confiné malheureusement parce que on est
obligé d'avoir cette troisième d'autres
parce que même avec un troisième dose ça
ne peut ne pas suffire pour certaines
catégories de population donc on est
coincé par ce mode alternatif donc il
faut maintenant je pense avoir une
gestion
déjà qu'ils soutiennent l'hôpital public
qui soutient les soignants ont hurlé ont
bien du mal parce que on à la crise
hivernale qui arrivent les brochures it
les urgences pédiatriques qui sont déjà
débordés avec les banques sur hit on a
la grippe classique on a toutes les
épidémies qu'on peut avoir plus les
traitements d'urgence avc etc qui arrive
donc il faut soutenir l'hôpital
maintenant c'est la première chose à
faire promouvoir les traitements qui
arrivent le plus rapidement possible et
si la troisième dose fonctionne faire en
sorte que tout le monde apprenne sa
troisième dose mais arrêtez de diviser
arrêté de finalement remettre sur les
autres son incapacité entend gouvernants
en disant que c'est la faute des
français alors que non c'est la faute
parfois des modèles macron qui décide
seul sous le sceau du secret défense
alors on va regarder une première
réaction télégramme neely de la vallée
c'est le même discours qui hier un nom
nous dit l inacceptable après tout ce
que nous avons enduré est acceptée
inacceptable qu'un taux de vaccination
aussi élevé pierre tattevin c'est vrai
que ce message résume lui-même l'art
l'agacement de beaucoup de français il
ya eu beaucoup d'acceptation il ya un
taux de vaccination élevé et tout ça
pour ça
mais je pense que ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure et tout à fait vrai c'est
que ça serait beaucoup beaucoup pire si
on n'avait pas eu cette couverture
vaccinale qu'on a actuellement et pour
revenir sur ce que disait votre
chroniqueur là on a essayé les
traitements il ya eu beaucoup de
recherche sur les médicaments et à la
fin de l'année 2020 le constat était que
y'a rien de très convaincant et ce qui
arrive va nous aider un peu mais ça
n'aura jamais les faits qu'on lui des
vaccins qui ont bien 95 % d'efficacité
il ya juste besoin de faire cette dose
de rappel pour récupérer cette
efficacité des vaccins mais c'est
vraiment ça la porte de sortie c'est pas
les traitements pour l'instant on n'a
rien qui arrive à la cheville des
vaccins en terme de bénéfice pour la
population donc ce que je dirai à votre
avis de laval et la cape à l'air
vraiment très agacé c'est qu'il est tout
le monde trouve que c'est inacceptable
à la csn
se serait nettement pire si on n'était
pas vaccinée et vous pouvez regarder la
dernière vague qu'on a affrontée au mois
d'août il ya deux endroits en france où
ça a été une catastrophe c les deux
endroits où il n'était pas bien vaccinés
on a réussi à traverser cette vague de
fin août en métropole
relativement bien grâce à une couverture
vaccinale qui était bonne là ça va être
plus et parce que c'est l'hiver mais
c'est quand même le vaccin la clé du sud
alors pierre tattevin juste un chiffre
que j'ai vu passer ce matin qui m'a
beaucoup interloqué 48% des hospitalisés
vacciner 40 4% de non vacciner à
l'hôpital
expliquez-nous parce que là j'avoue que
j'ai pas bien compris ce chiffre ce
matin
en fait on a actuellement en france chez
les adultes une couverture vaccinale de
90% donc le fait que les gens qui sont
hospitalisés pour un co vite sont 50%
vacciner 50% non vaccinés c'est déjà une
preuve que le vaccin marche et parmi les
vaccinés convoi l'hôpital c'est vrai
dans mon hôpital mais c'est vrai dans
beaucoup d'endroits la plupart des gens
arrivent un peu au bout de l'efficacité
de la du schéma initial c'est-à-dire ils
sont à 5 3 à 6 mois et c'est pour ça
qu'on a vraiment l'impression qu'avec
cette dose de rappel les pays qui vont
commencer à le faire l'an d'ailleurs
assez bien montrer on va avoir une
réponse en anticorps beaucoup plus élevé
qu'avec le vaccin initial avec les deux
premières injections et qu'on va pouvoir
protéger les gens mieux et pendant plus
longtemps et c'est pas très original
c'est pareil avec des vaccins diphtérie
tétanos polio hépatites ont fait une ou
deux doses ont fait un rappel quelques
mois plus tard et ensuite on est
tranquille pendant des années s'est
montré un autre graphique également qui
monte quand même que il ya moins de
décès évidemment plus on est vaccinés -
il y adeux de décès marcel bénézet
regarder oui ce graphique qui est quand
même parlant et en tout cas factuel vous
vous le constatez même dans la clientèle
il ya eu quand même de l'inquiétude ou
les gens sont abondamment revenu dans
les restaurants voilà malgré
cette cinquième vannes qui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on travaille on n'a pas de
baisse pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
baisse il ya le le contrôle sanitaire
qu'il est qui les rassure le fait qu on
demande le passé ni terra entre ça
rassure le client parce que vous assure
quand vous avez un restaurant si on vous
demande pas le pas salutaire vous avez
des gens qui font demi tour parce qu'ils
disent ils sont pas sérieux ils vont
aller ailleurs donc il faut demander le
passe à lithaire aujourd'hui c'est nous
avons deux armes la vaccination il faut
il faut vacciner vacciner absolument et
le passe à lutter pour nos
établissements et surtout les gestes
barrière aujourd'hui on n'a que ça mais
il faut continuer à vivre moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il a besoin de vivre les
français ne supporteraient pas en
confinement il est né français sur ce
très bref ça se termine est réelle mais
il faut vivre avec ce virus s'adapte et
bien sûr se faire vacciner nous nous le
restaurateur être très vigilants à ce
que le pass and it et on nous envoie des
messages à nos adhérents et on envoie
sur facebook et sur les réseaux sociaux
demandez le pass alité et soyez très
vigilants l'état promet déjà plus de
contrôle de police en
raison beau jeu demande des contrôles de
police et que les gens fassent respecter
ce pas salutaire parce qu'il en va de
l'ouverture de l'établissement si ça se
passe mal on nous ferme war on peut pas
se permettre aujourd'hui nous avons une
économie nous avons des trésoreries qui
sont out je veux dire nous ces niveaux
pas quoi il ya des pge qui arrive à
rembourser mais c'est invivable c'est
pas possible aujourd'hui vous avez les
commerçants des restaurateurs et tous
les commerçants en général parce que moi
je suis un élu de la chambre de commerce
de paris
de france je vous assure que les
commerçants en général sont très inquiet
par ce qui s'est dit mais si on referme
c'est pas possible vos parents fermé
comment lui il ne faut surtout pas
refermé il faut vivre avec ce virus se
faire vacciner appliquez le plat
sanitaire le faire respecter et c'est je
pense qu'on va s'en sortir mais c'est
vrai que des fous alexis c'est vrai que
c'est important ce que nous dit marcel
bénézet parce que là il ya une petite
différence avec la première et jusqu'à
la quatrième balle c'est qu'avant il y
avait de quoi qu'il en coûte
le chômage partiel là il n'y a plus de
mesure rien que je mesure est
catastrophique il y avait déjà livré pas
le vaccin donc il y avait que ces
mesures là pour ralentir la progression
aujourd'hui on a le vaccin donc ce
serait pas entendable de dire qu'on va
remettre un couvre-feu remettre un
confinement 1 ce sera un échec total de
la stratégie vaccinale de la stratégie
sanitaire
inacceptable et pour le gouvernement et
pour les français donc évidemment il ya
quelque chose là qui ne fonctionne pas
on a l'impression de faire du surplace
depuis deux ans il se trouve que quand
même malgré la flambée des cas on n'a
pas une flambée aujourd'hui dans les
services de rémunération comme on a pu
la voir dans certains pics donc tant
mieux il faut continuer là-dessus et je
pense que il faut pas par contre là
c'est un conseil que je donne aux
gouvernements continuent avec la
stratégie de la peur du chantage de dire
attention si vous n'êtes pas sages du
rap à noël attention on va faire ça ça
ne marche plus les français en ont
ras-le-bol faut pas les traiter comme
des enfants je crois qu'il ya une
responsabilité réelle au sein de la
population au sein des professionnels de
la restauration est ailleurs les gens
savent très bien ce qu'ils ont à faire à
que le gouvernement arrête de nous
traiter comme des enfants à propos de
noël on est dans le coeur du débat je
vous propose d'écouter franck mettez un
directeur commercial de jouéclub
évidemment l'enjeu est très grand pour
lui il exprime tout même son inquiétude
en fait la question qui creusent c'est
d'ailleurs des mesures sanitaires yvon
entreprises et qui vont contraindre la
fréquentation dans les magasins dans le
fond de commerciaux on a vécu ça en 2001
donc aujourd'hui il ya toujours des
mesures de protection sanitaire qui sont
en vigueur dans les magasins nous
appliquons au quotidien par exemple chez
le club le masque est obligatoire pour
les clients comme pour les vendeurs et
donc on verra en fonction des décisions
du coût d'un moment de quelle façon il
faudra que nous adaptons les commerçants
sont très attentif à ce qui va être dit
aujourd'hui la priorité c'est les
clients c'est là que des clients en
magasin il ya une forêt
nos clients parce que il se projette sur
une fête de noël qui n'ont pas pu faire
l'an dernier on a des ventes qui sont en
avance par rapport à 2019 on est à + 1 %
par rapport à 2008 9 dont il y avait
l'anticipation et il ya de l'euphorie il
ya de l'envié et donc nous bien au
quotidien on accompagne tout cela pierre
tattevin c'est vrai qu'il ya de l'envié
on le constate certainement chacun
d'entre nous il ya du monde dans les
magasins souvent d'ailleurs un petit peu
confiné il commence à faire froid
l'épidémiologiste que vous êtes salle
inquiète de voir toutes ces personnes
réunies en un seul lieu confiné vous
craignez vraiment la catastrophe sur le
plan sanitaire
je suis infectiologues ont fait un super
tour dans ma vie et fait face à des
nations
oui je pense qu'il faut qu'on fasse
attention de ne pas faire d des
regroupements trop dense de populations
mal protégés et sans renouvellement
d'air après on la comprend la population
on vient de vivre quasiment deux ans de
cauchemar
donc il faut essayer de trouver un
équilibre entre les deux est
effectivement ne pas retourner au
confinement ça c'est vrai les fêtes de
noël avec la grand-mère de grand père
comment vous voyez ça également quelques
conseils
je pense qu'il est trop tôt pour se
prononcer la tueurs nés quand même un
mois il faut voir comment les choses se
passent on peut espérer que ça monte pas
trop et ça dure pas trop longtemps et
qu'on puisse avoir des réunions
familiales au moment de noël c'est donc
plus d'un mois mais c'est vraiment trop
tôt pour dire on a eu trop de surprise
avec ce virus donc un mois c'est trop
tôt marcel bénézet
on navigue vraiment à vue au moins bien
tattevin à la franchise de le dire il ya
vu depuis depuis deux ans maintenant il
faut pas on apprend à marcher en
marchant c'est le cas de le dire et qui
aurait pensé il ya trois mois il nous
arrive aujourd'hui à huit personnes mais
le gouvernement a dit on y serait sinon
c'est aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'ils
voulaient jouer dix années devant un
fait accompli il va vivre avec une vraie
ferveur se protéger protéger les autres
surtout et vivre avec ça en eau potable
pour pas se fermer les comptes ccc sein
de l'entreprise les magasins ils ont
fait du stock mais aujourd'hui décédé le
stock est là il faut le vendre donc il
peut pas se permettre d'un confinement
ni des réductions d'horaires il faut
travailler il faut nous laisser
travailler il faut respectez les gestes
barrière la vaccination la troisième
dose les masques si il faut dans des
calmes dès qu'il ya des endroits où il
ya beaucoup de monde mettre le masque et
enfants il faut il faut travailler il
faut rester c'est on peut pas se
permettre on confine et financier en
main la france n'a pas les moyens et les
français sont au bout du rouleau je vous
assure que psychologiquement c'est
dramatique on va regarder deux réactions
celle de sandra tout d'abord à le
chantage de noël sauver cette fête de
quoi des décisions politiques
inadmissible et délirante deuxième
réaction de nico aucune raison valable
de tuer cette fête encore une fois le
monde a besoin plus que jamais du
message de noël il est romantique ce
nico l ex poulain c'est vrai qu'on
parlait tout à l'heure des hôpitaux
c'est aussi là que le bât blesse c'est
parce qu'on n'a peut-être pas fait le
nécessaire
on n'a rien on attend 2 mondial oui
c'est dur de la santé pour colmater les
brèches pour faire que les soignants ne
partent pas en masse pour dire rester on
va un peu mieux vous considérez on n'a
pas investi massivement dans les
hôpitaux on n'a pas eu le temps c'est
arrivé très vite mais on affermissent
amélie en 2020 donc on a continué à
cette idée de l'hôpital de flux de la
fermeture des lits d'une logique
finalement
catastrophique délétère pour l'hôpital
public d'ailleurs une manifestation est
prévue le 4 décembre donc c'est pareil
ça c'est quelque chose et je crois que
l'idée aujourd'hui évidemment c'est
d'éviter que l'hôpital soit submergé
parce que chaque hiver c'est la même
chose depuis une quinzaine d'années une
vingtaine d'années avant le coc vides il
y avait la grippe chaque hiver qui déjà
posé des problèmes aux services
d'urgence là le danger c'est que c'est
les services pédiatriques qui sont en
danger avec les bronchiolites on n'a
jamais vu des enfants aussi jeunes leur
début en chrome lite on a maintenant les
services d'urgence qui disent on ne
pourra peut-être pas traiter des cas de
crise cardiaque d'avc parce que on est
bernard on n'a plus les moyens les
soignants ne sont pas là on n'a pas les
mains qu'il faut l'alerté partout et on
a un ministre qui est surnage au milieu
de tout ça qui al'air obnubilé par la
vaccination évidemment il faut le faire
mais derrière il ya tout un système de
santé qui est en train de s'effondrer et
lui qui est en train de dire non tout va
bien on va rappelez-vous les annonces
d'olivier veyrat au tout début nous
sommes prêts on a vu on n'est vraiment
pas prêt et je crois que c'est ça et
cette stratégie du chantage de la
division aussi de la haine envers les
non vaccinés qui seraient les virus les
enfants aussi qui font peur aux grands
parents il faut arrêter et justement si
noël effectivement c'est un message de
concorde et d'amour il faut le remettre
sur la table on manque d'amour dans ce
pays il ya trop de maltraitance donc
avant il va peut-être falloir dire il
faut colmater finalement cette division
organisé par une nouvelle macro et dire
ça suffit je suis présente tous les
français on a besoin peut-être aussi la
de se calmer et de dire on va faire un
effort collectif tous ensemble en
arrêtant de montrer les uns ou les
autres et de les monter les uns contre
les autres ce assez délétère ça c'est
scandaleux et c'est un coup d'épée au
pacte républicain et pierre tattevin ça
sera le mot de la fin pour pierre
bénazet et pierre tattevin vous le
constatez vous cette situation de
craquage entre guillemets dans les
hôpitaux c'est vrai qu'il ya de plus en
plus de mal à d'ailleurs on sait jamais
trop quand on a le premier rhume savoir
sur neil qu'ovide ou passe et c'est vrai
qu'il ya de plus en plus d'infections
aujourd'hui vous le constatez vous à
rennes
oui c'est tout à fait leur escalier
alexis poulain assez que l'hôpital est
en tension même avant le coc vide on
avait tous les hivers des moments où on
avait du mal à tenir le coup et est là
c'est un peu la cerise sur le gâteau
c'est ce qui rend l'hôpital public
encore plus en difficulté
donc il faut qu'on se serre les coudes
mais ça peut pas ça peut pas être résolu
en quelques mois ce problème là il faut
qu'on forme plus de gens qu'on
investisse plus dans l'hôpital public et
malheureusement on n'aura pas le temps
de le faire pour les mois qui
s'annoncent
marcel bénézet le mot de la fin pour
vous est-ce que vous avez des prémices
de ce qui va être dit demain des indices
vous avez déjà j'imagine le contact est
peut-être le gouvernement faire une
petite forme de lobbying de la rigueur
de la rigueur sur l'état sanitaire bien
sûr sur les gestes barrières mais ce que
j'ai peur c'est les jeunes parce qu'on
va faire masser on reste de repartir
dans le schéma qu'on a eue de l'année
dernière et on peut pas se permettre
financièrement aujourd'hui nous avons la
profession qui est vraiment dans une
situation difficile et qui voit des
dettes qui se sont accumulés et qu'il va
falloir annoncé aujourd'hui non il faut
travailler donc moi je demande de la
vigilance de la compréhension nos
clients comprennent ils aiment d'aller
au restaurant qui se décrit sortie dès
qu'ils arrivent montrent leur téléphone
pour qu'on prenne le pas sanitaires il
faut qu il nous faut travailler il faut
nous laisser travailler merci beaucoup
marcel bénézet alexis poulin et pierre
va devoir d'avoir été avec nous en
direct ce soir